お時間は過ぎておりますが
ご質問などございましたら
何かご意見とかご質問とかございます
今回例えば少し心が綺麗になって
そして死んだ場合 次の転生の時は綺麗な心で機能して
次の命から  うんうん うん
ちょっと複雑 言ってることは
心を綺麗にして死んだ場合は
その綺麗にした心が次の肉体に移るところのしているところ
あ 綺麗にしたところは
次も次の新しい人生でもその綺麗なところは持っていける
持っていけるということですね
それはどの程度で自分が心を綺麗にしたかということなんですよ
復習して復習してもう慣れてしまっていれば
自分が綺麗な心だとも知らないんだと
それぐらい一体になっているんだったら
もう癖が残るんですよ
まあ例えば今世でもう悪いこともするわ
良いこともするわ いろいろ
もうミックスで それで死ぬ時は良い心が出てきて
もう良いところに生まれたりするでしょ
あまり復習してないんだから
心は同じレベルなんですね
幸福なところで生まれても
だから一考の先行で良いところに生まれる
でもこの人は復習してないんですね
善行為は だから心ももう癖がついてない
だから本来の悪のプロペンシティ
今の傾きはもうそのままなんですね
で 今世で大胆な良いことをしなくたっても
小さな小さな良いことをしながら
もう復習して心の中身まで綺麗にしちゃうと
これかなりの癖なんですよ
それはそう簡単には消えません
それで他のところに幸福なところに生まれても
その時は心は綺麗に保たれます
しかし すべて無常だから
それで永久永久ということじゃないんです
復讐っていうのは復讐で身につくんだから
別なもの 復讐しちゃうと
あれ また変えちゃうでしょ
だから人格向上は一応頂点にまで持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
悟りまで  善行為になれるというふうに復習するという中に
自分がやった過去の善行為を思い出して
心の中で善行為をやったというのを思い出すことも
入ってます うん  あの  性善説と性悪説というのがあると思うんですけど
人間というのはもともと
さっきの長老のお話では
なんか悪い方にいっちゃってるんで
性悪説っていう感じなんでしょうか
ちょっと複雑ですね 大体あの世間で性悪説と性善説という考え方があって
性性 もともと人間の本性が善か悪かという話で
今の長老のお話ですと
性悪説の方うんうん そういう
ああ あの それがまあプラクティカルというかね
具体的には悪で取った方が正しいんですよ
観念的に見るならば 性善でも別にどうったことはないんです
しかし 性善ということは
我々一度も経験したことがないんですよ
本来の善は 我々ずっと輪廻で経験するのはもう悪なんですよ
だからそれを潰さなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから実践面でやっぱり悪で取るんです
無明ということは仏教用語であるでしょ
だから本来は無明であると
無知であるともいうことはないんですよ
もう悪なんですね その場合は
でもこれは断言的に悪っていう意味じゃないんです
だから では心からこの無明を取り除いたらどうでしょうかというと
お釈迦様は言うのは心すごい綺麗だと
完全輝いていますよと
だからその言葉だけ取っちゃうと
心は本来輝いているということは言えます
その言葉も仏典にあります
でもせいぜい参加証でしかないんですよ
数えてみたっても でも生命は無明
無明と渇愛にやられちゃって
無常なる輪廻転生しているんだという経典というのはもう何百単義なんです
経典の数は だからちょっと民主主義的に
はそちらにするんです
まあそういうあの 何といいますか
このある一つのこのドグマとしてっていう話じゃないんですよ
仏教はドグマじゃないんだからね
いつでも実践で見るんですよ
悪いことするとな あんたもともといい人間だよと言ったところで
ああそうですか わかったというふうに立ち上がってくるならばいいんですよ
あ もともと私はいい人間だから
別に今何やったってもいいんじゃないかと
本来の心は変わりませんので言っちゃうとアウトでしょ
だから我々実践的に言う
あんた悪いことしちゃうと
それは心の中まで入るんだよと
悪漬けになるんだよと
だからもうなんていうのはふざけてでもやるなよというふうにすごい厳しく言うんです
でないと人格向上は出てこないんですよ
では 回向の文を唱えます
回向の文 仏道僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
拝を踏み 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして平安が与えられますように
サッビーテヨイバンジャントゥ
サッバローゴウィナッサトゥ
マテーバワットワンタラーヨ
スキーディーガーユクーバワ
バワトゥサッバマングラッカントゥ
サッバデーヴァタ サッバブッダヌーバヴェーナ
サッバダンマヌーバヴェーナ
サッバサンガーヌーバヴェーナ
サダースッティバワントゥティ
アビワダナシーリッサニッチャンワッダパチャイノ
チャターロダンマワッダンティ
アーユワンノースカンバラン
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
では 長い時間大変ご苦労いたしました
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました